Henry Cavill's work on Netflix's The Witcher
is fantastic, but the series' supporting cast
members are memorable too.
Chief among them: Lars Mikkelsen, who plays
the conflicted illusionist Stregobor.
Here's why this guy looks so familiar.
Though he's currently earning rave reviews
for portraying a conniving dark wizard with
a piercing intellect, The Witcher is hardly
Lars Mikkelsen's first go at breaking bad
on the small screen.
As it happens, the actor has had a pretty
great run playing scheming intellectual sorts
in movies and TV shows over the years.
As such, we'd wager that many of you who are
certain you've seen Stregobor's face before
just might be familiar with the genius-level
blackmailing baddie Charles Augustus Magnussen
one of the most devious villains to ever face
off against Holmes and Watson in the BBC's
pitch-perfect Sir Arthur Conan Doyle adaptation
Sherlock.
"You just know things.
How does that work?"
"I just love your little soldier face.
I want to punch it.
Bring it over here a minute."
Mikkelsen appeared in the episode "His Last
Vow," which found Holmes and Watson on the
hunt for a collection of deeply personal letters
which were being used as blackmail against
Lady Elizabeth Smallwood.
Their search set Holmes and Watson on a collision
course with Mikkelsen's duplicitous media
mogul a course that ends with Magnussen ultimately
outwitting Holmes, thus leaving the legendary
sleuth no course of action but to shoot Magnussen
in the head in hopes of saving the lives and
futures of all those who matter to him.
House of Cards showrunner Beau Willimon was
quick to seize on Mikkelsen's knack for playing
brainy, brutal bad guys when the series was
casting a key supporting role in Netflix's
breakout drama series.
If you count yourself as a fan of House of
Cards, then we're pretty sure a big, fat light
bulb just went off in your head, because Mikkelsen's
turn as the series' calculating, shamelessly
manipulative Russian leader Viktor Petrov
remains one of the high points on a show that
saw dramatic peaks and valleys over its tumultuous
six-season run.
Of all the memorable supporting players who
came and went over the course of the series'
73 episodes, Mikkelsen's potent, 13-episode
arc as Petrov is the one that continues to
stand tallest, if only because the character's
presence was so frequently felt even when
he wasn't onscreen.
"If people don't like the job you're doing,
they vote you out of office.
If they don't like the job I'm doing, they
topple statues.
Blood is spilled.
Chaos takes over."
It's hard to imagine that Netflix brass wasn't
keenly aware of Mikkelsen's powerful screen
presence on House of Cards, and it seems possible
that the actor's ability to hold his own against
some serious dramatic heavy hitters on that
series helped secure his casting on The Witcher.
If you've never taken a moment to check in
with either House of Cards or Sherlock, it's
entirely possible you don't recognize Mikkelsen's
face at all.
But even if that is the case, the actor's
voice might ring a bell.
You might recognize his performance from a
certain galaxy far, far away, specifically
the Star Wars franchise's compelling animated
series Star Wars Rebels.
Rebels follows the adventures of a starship
crew who bravely stand up to the Galactic
Empire, which is busy traversing the galaxy
stamping out the remnants of the Jedi Order.
Joining a star-studded cast of talent including
the likes of David Oyelowo, Clancy Brown,
and more, Mikkelsen lent his voice to the
show by stepping into the boots of the feared
Imperial leader Grand Admiral Thrawn, who
frequently tormented the ragtag group of rebels
throughout the series.
Mikkelsen has a number of projects in the
works; to name just a couple, he'll be featured
in the upcoming crime drama The Knife Thrower,
and on the Danish small screen serial Grow,
which is currently shooting.
In the meantime, though, he's enjoying the
raised profile that comes with his supporting
role on The Witcher.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.